I think that we love this though you
love hot dogs and I love hot dogs I do
love hot dogs I do when did this start
this passion um oh gosh yeah when did my
love affair with the hot dog begin well
I've always loved hot dogs but my best
friend Courtney McBroom who was also the
food consultant on U oh yeah you can see
it right there and lessons and chemistry
yeah food consultant on lessons in
chemistry she started she's the
president of the hot dog appreciation
club and I'm a proud member obviously
nice um yes and so this is segue into um
a hot dog appreciation Festival that's
once a year at my family's house my
stepdad dresses as a hot dog
um it's a lot um but it's a it's a
really great it's super fun oh yeah you
can see it all going down so I hear you
have a debate with that fanny pack get
it um I hear there's a debate yeah but
if if a sandwich or if the hot dog is a
sandwich or if it's separate if it's a
hot dog it's not I think a hot dog is a
hot dog I think to say that it is a
sandwich is blasphemy um but Courtney
thinks that it's a sandwich and it's
very hard to argue with someone who is
the president of the hot dog
appreciation Club it's like why am I
fighting reality I don't know it's kind
of fun you know what's funny is I don't
I've never thought about it maybe y'all
have but I've never thought about but it
is bread with meet in between I know but
it's connected and that makes all the
difference okay okay okay okay okay okay
but what about a Subway sandwich like a
s you know that's a sub is connected am
I blowing your mind right now it's not
connected it's not connected it's not
connected it's super connected I want to
see toally show hands how many people I
won't be offended I'm just curious how
many people think a hot dog is a
sandwich see the people who sayone are
emphatic that it's a no and we don't
even really know why but it's just wrong
but I'm very proud of the like five
people that stood strong on their belief
that yes thank you you stood with me we
were alone on an island but it's okay I
never thought about it before and then I
was like well it kind of is like a sub
sandwich provoking yeah thought
provoking for sure thought provoking
[Music]
well
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home